the ceasefire between israel and
hamas-led palestinian militants in gaza
continues to hold on the second day
after coming into effect
with calm restored thousands of
displaced palestinians are now starting
to return to their homes
as gazans take stock eight groups warn
that the devastation after
11 days of air strikes and rocket
attacks could take
years to rebuild
before rebuilding homes and businesses
the arduous work of cleaning up rubble
needs to be dealt with
the destruction left by israeli
airstrikes launched in response to hamas
fired rockets
has added fresh scars to gaza's
landscape
and there's also been a psychological
impact
on the people living here
we were very afraid of the israeli
airstrikes i didn't sleep
we didn't have time to sleep it was all
very hard
i thank god that i came out of this war
unharmed but my feelings are confused
i can't say whether i'm happy or sad
it's very confusing
humanitarian aid is arriving in gaza
and it's urgently needed
46 as i mentioned before of essential
drugs and 33
of essential medical supplies are at
zero stock so even if
um the hospitals and clinics were
functioning
they wouldn't be able to provide the
care and services
fully anywhere because they like the
staffs
among those pledging to help in the
hamas controlled enclave
is the united states
hamas is a terrorist organization we
recognize that that
but that doesn't mean we should not be
in gaza rebuilding gaza for all those
innocent people who in fact
have been hurt and and had been
collateral damage
it may take many months and years to
rebuild the damage done
in just a matter of days talks to ensure
the egypt
brokered ceasefire between israel and
the palestinians holds
are ongoing a key step towards finding a
lasting solution to this
decades-old conflict let's speak now to
our correspondent tanya kramer who is
in gaza city tanya good to have you with
us it's
day two after rockets stopped hailing
down
on gaza you've been talking to people
there is there any sense of life
returning to normal
well we've seen on friday many people
heading home actually those people who
were at displaced or were forced
to flee to seek shelter in un schools
uh several thousands uh had uh to flee
from their homes and they were of course
assessing their damage coming home some
of them found
their houses to be so damaged that they
can't live in them
anymore others had smaller damages and
of course others were just
sprinting out after 11 days picking up
the pieces after 11 days of
bombardment israeli bombardment here in
gaza but also
rockets being fired into the south of
israel now they were checking on their
neighborhood
they were checking on neighbors on the
damage and destruction in the city
their mixed feelings are among people on
the one hand you have the narrative the
official narrative
of victory on the other hand i had
people saying that the toll on the
civilian
population has been very high and people
of course also very wary
of what is there to come if you know the
underlying issues here are not addressed
focus is now on getting aid to bomb
shattered gaza
what can you tell us about humanitarian
efforts where you are
well i think the damages and destruction
is still
assessed by the humanitarian
organizations
uh here in gaza we also know that
several countries have already bledged
with a humanitarian aid to come in and
we saw on friday first shipment of
humanitarian aid
coming in through keram shalom that is
the main crossing for goods
from israel into gaza but i think that
one of the
main issues will be the rebuilding of
gaza and that will be rather complicated
because
israel restricts building material
coming into gaza
because it might be used by hamas for
dual use for the
for the building of tunnels for example
and
of course we've seen after the war in
2014 that there was a special mechanism
to deal with this issue because most of
the international community
also doesn't deal directly with hamas
who's ruling gaza
tania karima thank you very much for
your update from gaza city
shawnee rosannas is with me now she's a
dw journalist and an expert on middle
eastern affairs shawnee welcome to the
program
tensions are still running high what
needs to happen for this truce to really
hold
well it seems like both sides want to
hold it you know we need to keep in mind
behind every thing we see it's intent
and we see the political intent
um on both sides to start or to bring
upon this escalation was high and now
they understand they got all they could
have
gotten from this esc you know from this
round of
conflict and now they need to keep it
down and it seems like it's going to
hold for now but we always need to be
cautious in the middle east you know
both sides have been claiming victory
after this last round of fighting but
really are there any winners
in this well if you ask the the people
counting their dads and you know burying
their families then there's never
any uh victory in a war but hamas on his
side
has seen victorious right from the very
first rocket shot at jerusalem you know
bringing together the connection between
what's happening in al-aqsa mosque
after israeli police forces raided and
stormed the galaxy mosque during
ramadan days and so for him to make that
linkage between
between itself as the leadership of the
palestinian people as a defender of
jerusalem
for them that's already a victory and
they have managed to stay very strong
with their um
with their offensive on israeli targets
throughout the 11 days of
of of of this operation so for them
there's great achievement on their side
the israelis on the other hand
you know they want to claim victory by
having shown you know their resilience
and so on but but it's
clear to everybody that this is not
going to make any seismic
changes to what we're seeing the
dynamics on the ground if you want to
see
something changing on the long term
there's got to be more there's got to be
talks that's got to be aid
far more to make this sustainable
let's talk about the situation in the
west bank because that is where most
palestinians live
how has this latest escalation
reverberated there
we've seen um for hamas a great success
in making
the lincoln to jerusalem as we just
mentioned that means that getting a lot
of support from the west bank and
jerusalem palestinians
in the last days of the operation like
during the whole uh time
we've been focusing on gaza but in the
west bank there have been 20 casualties
penny people who lost their lives in
clashes with israeli forces so
um and we've seen yesterday in the
celebrations uh in the al-aqsa mosques
we see
hamas flags this is not a common sight
it's at least it
used to be a very rare sight because the
west bank jerusalem were always by you
know ruled by the dominance
of the palestinian authority hamas
leadership was not as strong as
fatah is in the west bank so what we're
seeing now
and the biggest fear of israel would be
seeing things flaring up in the west
bank and that would
make things far more complicated um for
now it seems to be under control
but it's the tension is quite high if
still you know lasting
where do you see the situation going
from here well the key would be
how do how to for israel for the
americans for
the west bank leadership of the
palestinians that is the palestinian
authority
how can they regain control over the
situation and
that means how can they weaken hamas and
aid seems to be the main
key here um what the americans are
trying to do maybe with the support of
the emirates for example who were
now connected to israel normalized ties
with israel last year during the um
abraham accords
they will try to see if there's a way
for them to control aid
in the way it you know it's being
channeled into
infrastructure development in gaza with
the help of the west bank
leadership of fatah and that will help
strengthen that leadership who's never
been as weak as we see it now
and it will help gazans of course and
hopefully americans israelis hope
that it will also help weaken hamas
hamas on it on the other hand
is backed by qatar by iran but that axis
that is straight you know giving great
money and
helping them gain weapons and build
infrastructure
um that axis is a common old axis
between
um sooner forces and more shia forces
in the arab muslim world it's not a
conflict that's going to go away
so fast so soon shawnee rosanes thank
you very much for your analysis
thanks nicole